[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire c'est toute l'europe qui est
actuellement aux prises avec l'épidémie
de kobe de 19
l'europe qui est la seconde zone la plus
endeuillée du monde après l'amérique
latine alors le royaume uni l'irlande la
grèce l'italie ont reconquis n'est tout
ou une partie de leur population comme
la france mais ailleurs comment ça se
passe sur la suède
les avis divergent tellement que nous
allons organiser prochainement un débat
sur ce pays le seul à n'avoir pas
confiné sa population aujourd'hui nous
allons nous intéresser à quatre pays
très différent de l'union européenne
la finlande qui a l'un des taux de décès
les plus faibles d'europe et des niveaux
d'infections cinq fois inférieur à la
moyenne européenne mais aussi
l'allemagne l'espagne et la slovaquie le
premier pays du monde à tenter une
campagne de dépistage massif de toute sa
population et donc pour nous expliquer
comment ça se passe ailleurs nous avons
invité gwenaëlle beauvoir qui est
sociologue chercheuse à l'université
d'helsinki vous vivait en finlande
depuis une vingtaine d'années comment ça
se passe alors en finlande on va dire
dans l'ensemble ça se passe plutôt bien
qu'ils ont par rapport au reste de
l'europe
les chiffes été très bons en était le
malheureusement c'est un petit peu
remonté en octobre est sans commune
mesure avec le reste de l'europe
évidemment au cours des deux dernières
semaines en finlande euros chiffre à peu
près 45 à cent mille habitants donc
c'est le taux le plus bas d'europe en ce
moment donc on voit un petit peu plus de
masques qui est toujours pas obligatoire
juste recommandé et seulement depuis le
mois d'octobre et la vie plus ou moins
normal disons un peu au ralenti mais pas
d'euros confirmant à l'horizon et la vie
d'un peu plus calmes et soirée se
termine plus tôt jean françois gonnard
vous vivez en allemagne vous êtes
consultant santé publique vous avez plus
de 40 ans d'expérience sur le terrain
notamment en afrique subsaharienne au
moyen-orient dans les balkans ou en asie
centrale vous pouvez donc faire des
comparaisons y compris avec la france
comment ça se passe en allemagne
écoutez en allemagne il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes de la part des autorités
fédérales vous savez que la sentait une
d'une compétence de chacun des 16 états
d'allemagne
on est dans ce qui s'appelle confinement
le pg c'est à dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'interdictions
est ce que la principale force de
l'albanais encore une fois toujours le
trop social c'est à dire que les gens
vérifie que les autres biens masque est
bien etc
ça a beaucoup sauver l'allemagne dans le
premier confinement le deuxième
s'annonce un peu plus difficile on va
dire il ya à peu près onze mille cas par
jour
on n'est pas encore au taux de mortalité
de la france en des quatre fois
inférieur donc voilà mais il ya des
interdictions sur beaucoup de choses les
bars les cafés les restaurants des
réunions familiales depuis de 10
personnes il reste quand même les
coiffeurs ouvert enfin des petites
exceptions comme ça mais voilà donc un
peu plus inquiétudes et des mesures un
peu plus peu plus serré quand même mais
pas au point de la france n'y a pas de
vérification par les gendarmes de du
kilomètre par avoir ce genre de détails
tout à l'heure délice l'élite veste rage
vous êtes conseillère de pablo iglesias
qui est le secrétaire général de pau des
mousses et depuis neuf mois le deuxième
vice-président du gouvernement de pedro
sanchez
il est aussi ministre des droits sociaux
et de l'agenda 2030 vous travaillez donc
avec lui comment ça se passe à madrid en
plus tôt en espagne la situation en
espagne ont piqué bien sûr peu compliqué
contre landes et le pays le sixième pays
le plus au monde par la crise du
politique et c'est un pays qui a été
très touché par la crise économique de
2008 et donc c'est une crise qui s'est
enchaîné avec les sanitaires
de plus que la santé publique espagnole
elle a été touchée par toutes ces
réductions de budget du gouvernement
on était antérieure au gouvernement
actuel et comme tu eric un gouvernement
de coalition où il ya le parti
socialiste et le parti actuellement il
n'y a pas de confinement
c'est vrai que l'espagne est un pays et
décentralisé du coup c'est pas la même
gestion compense la première vague a été
gérée elle par le gouvernement central
est actuellement c'est les communautés
autonomes ils prennent en charge ces
mesures du coup il ya des territoires
qui sont confinés elle était pas qu'ils
le sont pas et la situation est un peu
d'inquiétude et voilà les gens les
citoyens prend un peu comme jérôme
texier vous vous travaillez dans une
entreprise française implanté en
slovaquie vous vivez là bas depuis 15
ans d'être marié à une slovaque vous
avez ouvert récemment un compte twitter
pour partager en français des
informations sur ce petit pays de cinq
millions et demi d'habitants membre de
l'union européenne depuis 2004 sur sa
façon de lutter contre la pandémie en
particulier et je les dis au début de
cette émission c'est le premier pays au
monde qui va tester un dépistage massif
de toute la population n'en parlera en
détail tout à l'heure mais a priori
comment ça se passe comment ça va même
en slovaquie écoutez tout va bien ce
penalty alors pour la totalité de la
population on nous sommes tous ce qu'on
appelle un semis confinement du fait des
tests massif
bien sûr et les décisions qui ont été
prises à savoir si les personnes
pouvaient se déplacer ne pas se déplacer
donc quand vous le rappeler la slovaquie
un petit pays il ya quand même eu une
une organisation opérationnelle qui
était mise en place pour ce test massif
aux normes actuelles à savoir que la
slovaquie dès la première vague a été un
des pays dès le début du mois de mars
qui a fermé ses frontières fermées les
écoles et les espaces culturels
alors qu'il n'y avait
seulement que 21 décès beaucoup bossé
tous ensuite dans la plupart des pays
européens pendant la période des
vacances d'été il ya eu un déconfinement
et il est vrai qu'avec le nouveau
gouvernement qui est arrivé justement à
la mi mars il y a eu des décisions qui
ont été prises le 17 octobre pour
justement faire un test massif qui a été
le premier qui a été effectué le
week-end du 31 au 1er novembre qu'avec
seulement deux semaines de préparation
donc dans l'ensemble il ya un semis
confinement part de celui confinement
pas de profits - keita et bien
commençons pas la finlande
[Musique]
alors on est de retour avec gwenaëlle
beauvois en chine qui gonal en mars déjà
le confinement en finlande avait été
assez léger 1
c'est à dire que les écoles les nuls
diversité ont fermé mais les gens
avaient le droit de sortir de chez eux
les finlandais eux
la plupart des magasins sont restés
ouverts alors comment expliquez-vous
comment explique-t-on en finlande le
fait qu' il y ait des résultats aussi
bons il ya plusieurs facteurs pour
expliquer cette situation
déjà on peut dire que la finlande avoir
mon bien géré la crise et que les
niveaux d'infections sont cinq fois
inférieur à la moyenne de l'union
européenne
une des raisons principales c'est que la
finlande a réagi très tôt dès le 16 mars
l'état a déclaré l'état d'urgence et à
instaurer un smic confirmant donc comme
vous disiez on pouvait encore sorti on
n'avait pas les limitations de 1
kilomètre d'une heure par jour donc on
avait le droit de se déplacer
relativement facilement mais les écoles
vers sites et musées bibliothèques par
an tout a été fermé et aussi ils ont
fait pas mal de restriction niveau les
frontières 40 elle recommandé quand on
voyage
elles ont aussi confiné la région de
aussi manqué la région du sud du pays où
se trouve m 6 qui donc on ne pouvait pas
sortir ni rentrer dans la région de 12 6
mois et comme vous le disais la faim
dans la pas vraiment connu un véritable
confinement vous pouvez vraiment sortie
ratée librement n'y avait pas de dames
en 2 prévu etc explique aussi c'est que
les hôpitaux n'ont pas été en danger à
l'heure en ce moment le nombre de
personnes en seront intensifiés autour
de 13 donc sans commune mesure avec
d'autres pays en europe et délais dès le
début de l'épidémie
les hôpitaux ont vraiment sont vraiment
attendu à un scénario catastrophe qui
finalement des paravents arriver donc on
s'inquiétait plus dans les petites
structures que dans les grands hôpitaux
mais ils ont su gérer vraiment la
situation est aussi la finlande a fait
des tests de des campagnes de tests
assez rapidement qu'ils ont plutôt bien
marché donc la finlande a vraiment su
prendre des mesures
très rapidement les mesures qui ont été
lui qui paraissent beaucoup plus légère
que dans le reste de l'europe mais qui
ont été très bien très bien suivi ce qui
explique en partie à
les très bons résultats la finlande
alors à bâtir de la mi mai tout est
redevenu à peu près normal les enfants
sont retournés à l'école les cafés les
restaurants les bars vous avez même
rouvert les discothèques pendant l'été
chose impensable chez nous on a dit que
ce serait de la folie d'ouvrir les
discothèques
vous l'avez fait vous n'êtes pas morts
vous êtes toujours là alors c'était quoi
il se trouve que déjà les tests en
finlande
quand on se fait tester on a les
résultats de 24 heures après je crois ou
même moins dans le service public
il ya eu un peu de hors jeu mans c'est
normal on allait résister relativement
rapidement et dans le privé par exemple
si vous allez à la médecine du travail a
les résultats en moins de six heures
dont on peut se faire on peut avoir un
peu voir le test le matin et avoir le
résultat devrait jouer très rapidement
c'est sûr que pour la france par exemple
et nora qui les capacités assez
importante elle et vous avez une
application de traçage informatique qui
semble assez efficace il se trouve que
les îles les finlandais l'ont
téléchargée massivement je crois un
million d'entre vous la télécharger le
premier jour depuis il ya eu un million
et demi de plus enfin bref 42% de la
population à télécharger l'application
et elle marche
oui exactement donc l'application qui
équivalente aux stocks au vide corona
bellecour en finnois a été chargé deux
millions cinq pour 5 millions 5
d'habitants donc c est près de la moitié
de la population est comme vous le
disait à un million d'une seule journée
donc ça a été vraiment un succès
extrêmement rapide
évidemment les experts considèrent que
ça peut être une des raisons pour
laquelle la finlande s'en sort mieux que
d'autres pays européens
en plus cette application est disponible
en plusieurs langues en finnois
évidemment mais aussi on suédois que la
deuxième langue nationale du pays un peu
plus tard aussi en anglais donc pour les
gens comme moi qui vivent ici qui
parlent pas forcément
couramment la langue ça peut aider quand
même beaucoup d'étrangers qui ne
maîtrisent pas totalement ils ont pensé
aussi aux étrangers ce qui est une bonne
chose
donc ça donne vraiment la possibilité à
tout le monde de pouvoir être au courant
de de l'application de comment ça
fonctionne et entre le 1er septembre et
le 15 septembre 35 % des personnes
diagnostiquées avec des infections ont
utilisé l'application pour signer les
infections donc ça a vraiment été un
succès assez important probablement un
des plus grands succès à un des plus
grands succès au monde d'après un
sondage les deux tirs les finlandais
considère que c'était le c'était leur
devoir civique de télécharger
l'application est que comme c'était une
recommandation de l'institut finlandais
pour la santé le bien-être
ils ont fait tout à fait naturellement à
seulement 3 % des personnes interrogées
déclarent que les préoccupations
concernant l'utilisation abusive des
données personnelles a été une raison
pour ne pas télécharger l'application
qui avant - d'énormes différences avec
la france et c'est avec déploiement les
plus réussis une application pour
l'arrêter l'échelle infections de corona
en termes de couverture de la population
dans le monde entier alors le masque des
pas obligatoire en finlande mais je
trouve qu'on dit vous êtes enfin ce pays
est un pays nordique et que donc la
distanciation physique y est plus grande
et puis on est plus casaniers aussi est
ce que c'est ça vous semble vrai ça
n'est pas un cliché
oui et non il faut c'est sûr qu'il faut
faire attention pas tomber dans les
clichés mais c'est sûr que par exemple
les finlandais se font pas la bise c'est
vrai qu'il ya une distanciation social
qui est peut-être un peu plus importante
déjà au départ donc bien sûr et casanier
dans un sens oui mais dans un autre sens
je pense que l'éléphant des soucis extra
sportifs et ils font beaucoup
d'activités en extérieur ce qui était
aussi à quelque chose de très important
quand le devenu confinement c'est que
les gens voient la possibilité de sortir
quand vous savez à la fermière grand
pays avec les normands de forêt de
laquelle ticket hors bord de mer
beaucoup d espaces verts où les gens
sont beaucoup sorti même s'il faisait un
froid
tout le monde était dehors quand se
promener faire du jogging sortir son
cher donc je pense que ça a été vraiment
important pour que les gens gardent
vraiment un optimisme par rapport à la
situation en kit est extrêmement
dramatique même si on dit également que
on prends moi les transports en commun
en finlande
quand on se déplace davantage à vélo et
que donc c'est aussi une occasion de se
contaminer en moins c'est sur balles
en temps normal déjà les finlandais
utilise beaucoup le vélo c'est pas
autant que karen sternheimer qui accorde
beaucoup de pistes cyclables et
effectivement les gens ont d'autant plus
pris les vélos pendant la période du
confinement et ont continué lorsque les
chiffres dans les transports en commun
ont chuté je crois aux 70%
donc les gens mais maintenant après
beaucoup moins les transports en commun
ou j'apprends tous les jours pour venir
l'université il ya quand même eu très
peu de gens dans le métro à entrammes
concentrant manquer une grande
différence et les gens continuent à
utiliser le vélo et de manière assez
prononcé je sais que les chantiers ne se
sont jamais interrompu en finlande
est ce que le télétravail a été
important il nous chez nous il a été
beaucoup pour le premier confinement là
on voit bien qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
dire m qu'en est-il là bas la finlande a
vraiment réussi à négocier la transition
hat le télétravail je pense qu'ici ça
c'est fait sûrement de manière beaucoup
plus importante que dans d'autres pays
ce que la finlande un pays qui est
sûrement mieux équipés que d'autres pour
assurer cette transition rapide et sans
centre problème si a les infrastructures
qui sont déjà adaptés et les finlandais
sont déjà dans une certaine mesure
habitué à faire du télétravail en tout
cas dans certains secteurs évidemment
pour tout ce qui est restauration dans
les commerçants qui n'est plus difficile
évidemment mais le télétravail
recommandé dans tous les endroits où
c'est possible je pense qui si savamment
pas poser de problème est qu'en dise l
université les cours ont été faits ont
lieu quasiment immédiatement centre en
gros sans problème pense que dans
l'ensemble les finlandais ont même
plutôt apprécié d'avoir la possibilité
de faire du télétravail
de pouvoir beaucoup de finlandais
anciens un chalet à la campagne beaucoup
de gens sont allés l'accord pas pour
travailler vivre tout entend tout l'été
finalement ça s'est plutôt bien passé 1
par rapport à d'autres et je pense les
résultats non seulement la finlande a un
des taux de décès les plus faibles du
monde mais en plus ça son activité
économique n'a baissé depuis le début de
la crise du coronavirus que de 3 et
quelques pourcents je crois alors qu'en
moyenne en europe sert 11,6 pour cent de
de pertes de l'activité que de mick donc
c'est un c'est un bilan assez
extraordinaire est-ce que parmi nos
autres invités quelqu'un veut me poser
une question à agueda elle à gwenaëlle
non et bien continuons ce tour ce tour
d'europe reviendra vers vous tout à
l'heure gwenaëlle continuons avec avec
jean-françois donnart qui est consultant
en santé publique en allemagne qui a été
médecin également
alors évidemment l'allemagne
vous l'avez dit sont les länder qui
prennent les décisions sanitaire est
aujourd'hui si j'ai bien compris c'est
angela merkel chancelière et les patrons
des länder qui font en fait la politique
sanitaire de l'allemagne c'est ça oui ce
qui s'est passé c'est que les différents
länder ont commencé à voir des
politiques un peu différente notamment
il ya eu toute une histoire sur les
hôtels et sur le tourisme intra un train
allemagne 4e pays notamment la bavière
qui ne refusait que les personnes
originaires d'autres länder contre
hollande viennent en bavière et puis
souhait des autres ça s'est réglé au
niveau fédéral avec une grande rue de la
chancelière enfin de tous une équipe et
des 16 ministres président donc il ya
une forme de coordination national
fédéral on va dire oui mais il n'en
demeure pas mois que la la lutte au fait
tout ce qui est là d'épidémiologie du
coc vide et le travail sur les hôpitaux
le travail sur les mesures à prendre
c'est quand même de la responsabilité de
chacun des landes
donc voilà c'est celle avantages et les
inconvénients de la de l'allemagne c'est
un pays décentralisé donc les
responsabilités se prennent au niveau
décentralisé est bon parfois il ya six
morts de coordination mais ça se résout
à ses visiteurs en bonne intelligence
hague
donc elles ont dit que depuis le depuis
le 2 novembre
il ya sur l'ensemble du territoire
allemand on a quand même fermer les bars
les restaurants les cinémas les théâtres
les musées les salles de sport la times
eurent uniforme pour tout le territoire
à cette fois c'était une décision de la
coordination des
les présidents de l'inde donc à peu près
tout et faire et restent les coiffeurs
il reste vit tous les magasins
d'alimentation tout ce qui n'est pas
dans les listes parce que s'il ya une
liste très précise alors dans ses
magasins il ya une limitation du nombre
de personnes qu'il ya une personne pour
dix mètres carrés donc par exemple chez
le charcutier qui dans le village d'à
côté on voit qu'à quatre ou cinq
personnes une file dehors ça pose aucun
problème à personne
que dire d'autre allemagne sans que les
obligations de confinement soit marqué
précise se confine quand même c'est à
dire que le ils ont ralenti les des
contacts sociaux il il porte un masque y
compris dans les rangs des marchés dans
les choses comme ça on voit rarement des
gens sans base j'en ai vu une personne
tout à l'heure dans quel mais c'était
vraiment extraordinaire
les hôpitaux sont pas encore tout à fait
plein dans la capacité notamment
rénovation ils sont un petit peu
au-dessus de 50% donc il reste de la
place
ça c'est pour les pays limite mais on a
envoyé d'ailleurs de trois malades
récemment en allemagne on envoyait oui
j'ai l'impression qu'en allemagne la
discussion en france sur les produits
essentiels les produits pas essentiel
tout s'est fait en fonction du nombre de
mètres carrés et du nombre de gens qui
pouvaient rentrer à l'intérieur c'est à
dire que les mesures strictement
sanitaires y avait rien de moral est pas
de questions d'égalité de justice qui
entrent en ligne de compte
non non non à l'airé les bars les
restaurants sont fermés donc la partie
de la discussion que l'élu en france n'a
pas eu lieu en allemagne
mais oui c'est dans les autres
pourquoi on me levant qui rentre dans le
moule dans un supermarché est passée une
certaine limite et ben voilà c'est fini
je suis il faut attendre
donc ça c'est une bonne chose je pense
que dire d'autre l'allemagne avait on
pas enfin avait eu un faible
retentissement du premier confinement
lors du premier confirmant lors de la
première vague en utilisant beaucoup le
jeu me tester isolé puis les traces et
donc la halle est un peu des barbes
alice au début de cette deuxième vague
et je suis pas sûr que utilisent encore
tous à la france a été et est
entièrement des bordelais de soins du
lam et l'allemagne suma d'information là
dessus mais on en parle très peu
on a compris en allemagne pour toi
pourquoi elle avait été pourquoi
l'allemagne avait été avait eu l'air de
d'assez bien gérer la question lors de
la ville lors de la première vague et
pourquoi là avec la deuxième saab semble
se passer moins bien un festin mystère
épidémiologique
il semble que les premiers corps de la
première vague et étaient des gens issus
grosso modo de ce cluster de dautriche
là vous savez ce petit veut les ferries
l'allemagne et que coop les voilà quatre
les allemands l'ont su ils ont pris des
mesures aussitôt de tester tous les gens
qui revenaient de cet endroit là et de
suivre les cas contacts ce qu'on a fait
un peu en france dans cette histoire
vers saint gervais par now on s'appelle
sa bosse et ils en sont restés là ya pas
eu beaucoup plus de deux classes terre
dangereux comme on a eu à mulhouse comme
on en a eu dans l'oise et c'est donc
ils n'ont pas eu de grands clusters
maintenant j'attends un peu de voir ce
que désisterait si l'arraisonnement de
tout ça a hâte
voilà on n'a pas de jeu j'ai pas lu en
tout cas d'informations précises sur
pourquoi c'était comme ça à l'époque à
ce qu'il est et ce qui est maintenant le
constat c'est que on a eu on a commencé
par voir plusieurs clusters un petit peu
difficile notamment ceux kloster qui se
trouvait vers le nord ouest de
l'allemagne au dessus de la la ruhr et
on a eu des vraies mandé de nombreux cas
notamment chez les femmes qui
travaillent et danser ses abattoirs et
puis c'est un petit peu emballé de ce
côté là et maintenant c'est un petit peu
plus généralisée donc je sais pas si
leur politique de tester tracé isolé va
tenir le coup on va tenir le choc du
nombre de cas alors l'allemagne à la
religion des masques vous l'avez dit
c'est rare de voir des gens sans masque
pour autant est-ce qu'il ya ait ce
qu'est la police est ce qu ont contrôlé
ce qu'on verbalise en france on est très
fiers ministre de l'intérieur est très
fier de dire qu'il a bien fait que tant
de français ont été verbalisés voilà ça
fait partie de notre notre folklore
national
ce n'est pas le cas en allemagne non on
n'en parle pas même dans les journaux
locaux il ya aucune histoire de
personnes testées de personnes vous
savez l'allemagne est un pays où il ya
plus de contrôle social qu'il n'ya de
deux contrôles policiers
c'est valable pour les radars automobile
comme pour le reste c'est à dire c'est
votre voisin le monsieur qui est à côté
de vous dans le magasin etc qui va vous
dire que
il faudrait mettre un masque et cette
parole est presque une obligation parce
qu'elle est pris sur le ton de la
jonction
mais il n'y a pas de menace si rien du
tout on vous dit simplement monsieur il
faut porter un masque
donc voilà l'allemagne est un pays de
contrôle social et pas du tout fier
d'être de contrôle policier wagon il
existe quand même des radars il existe
quand même des gens qui sont flashés
dans mois creux vite mais voilà il faut
pas croire que les allemands
contrairement à ce qu'on pense sont très
disciplinés discipline discipline ils
ont un contrôle social c'est à dire que
on regarde ce que fait l'autre est on si
les directives comme la chancelière l'a
dit de se confiner de ne pas avoir trop
de contacts sociaux de ne pas avoir de
réunion de famille de plus de deux
familles avec 10 personnes au maximum
si vous voulez c'est c'est ce que dit la
chancelière c'est ce que je dis là je me
batte sur ceux de la loi c'est la
directive
si ce que dit la directive donc on obéit
on obéit à ça parce que parce que votre
voisin peut vous dire mais dis donc
machin tu restes tu peux te pas ce qui
est la directive de l'état c'est un des
pays où la l'activité économique a le
moins baissé ou en tout cas l'air parti
le plus rapidement a priori le
et sur le plan économique on a on ne
redoute pas un avenir comme nous plein
de chômeurs de faillite alors d'abord
l'allemagne fait aussi de petites
entreprises qui sont décentralisées qui
sont très local par exemple dans mon
village de 400 habitants il ya deux
entreprises ont une entreprise on va
dire internationale fia qui fait des
plongeons des plongées sous marines et
qui travaille en plongée sous marine
alors que renée en plein en pleine
plaine du rhin donc tous ces gens là ont
la capacité de de travailler avec peu de
gens etc
mais cette capacité leur a été autorisé
alors bien sûr il ya aussi des grosses
industries mais il n'y a pas une
interdiction de travailler en allemagne
les gens se déplacent pour aller
travailler les universités ont fermé
mais pas les écoles comme en france
voilà donc je pense que l'activité
économique a été conservé alors que par
exemple si on fait le con la comparaison
ça serait plutôt avec l'italie avec
toutes ces petites entreprises
italiennes qui ont beaucoup subi le
premier confinement et bien continuons à
lons dirigeons nous vers l'espagne avec
les listes vertes rage
l'élite en espagne alors on dit que
l'espagne est en revanche à des pays bas
oui c'est vrai il faut que je m'arrête
qui a le pardon j'allais continuer ya la
pause d'abord et on retrouve julie des
strass juste après pardonnez-moi l'euro
numérique à nous dit la bce existerait
donc parallèlement aux espèces sans les
remplacer
évidemment ils avancent masqués ils vont
pas vous dire dès le départ on fait ça
pour supprimer le cache la bonne et
c'est déjà numérique et c'est là où tant
que c'est numérique
c'est clair que le papier-monnaie france
est condamnée à terme
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que fait la banque
centrale elle récupère le système
technologique et elle se l'approprient
elle si vous avez le patrimoine open
aujourd'hui vous regardez avec anxiété
votre portefeuille tous les matins c'est
pas du tout le cas pour votre compte en
banque
on nous au pied sur votre bande ka
traditionnel ça s'inscrit dans un
mouvement qui est là depuis déjà
plusieurs années qui est d'avoir le plus
de renseignements de ce que vous faites
pour vous utilisez comme un produit
peut-être que c'est le le modèle dont on
rêve
nos dirigeants actuels
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on est énervé
donner le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ce
qu'il guérisse moi j'en ai marre qu'on y
passe un tour de tracteur avec nous que
leur campagne
il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente ils ont le sentiment d'être
des français de seconde zone comme s'ils
étaient invisibles ma forêt td quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
où
comment ça se passe ailleurs nous
faisons ce soir un petit tour des pays
de l'union européenne on est déjà passé
par la finlande par l'allemagne nous
voici en espagne avec l'idh veste rage
qui est conseillère du vice président du
gouvernement espagnol
alors lite
il ya le couvre feu il ya eu le
couvre-feu de pour quinze jours de 23
heures à 6 heures du matin c'est un
couvre-feu plus soft que celui qu'on
avait commencé par nous imposer à nous
en france à partir de 21h et c est vous
avez également avec un confinement
territoriale exactement la situation se
ressemblent à ces locaux l'ags a
expliqué pour l'allemagne en espagne au
lieu de lander on a les communautés
autonomes ils donnent que pendant la
première vague
c'était bien le gouvernement central qui
a pris en charge les tad alarme le
confinement en général du monde et pour
cette deuxième vague en raison de
certaines on va dire critiques de la
part des communautés autonomes comme
quoi l'espagne en tant qu état
décentralisé les communautés autonomes
aurait elle aussi les capacités et les
instruments pour pouvoir mettre en place
ces mesures
elles ont donc demandé est ce que
pendant le mois de juin donc après l'été
ce soit elle y prennent ces mesures en
charge maintenant comme on disait avant
on se retrouve avec des communautés
autonomes où il ya un confinement total
il y en a d'autres où les restaurants et
des cafés sont un mets à madrid par
exemple on a on doit rentrer chez nous à
23h à sortir jusqu'à 6h du matin mais
les bars et restaurants sont ouverts
savary on peut entre en 3d territoire et
alors il faut savoir que l'espagne est
un des pays où il ya eu plus de morts
par million d'habitants ses supérieurs à
la france c'est aussi un pays où
l'activité économique est le plus
souffert depuis pour les raisons que
vous expliquer au tout début de
l'émission depuis le début de la crise
du cordat virus donc a priori
est ce que c'est un pays traumatisé il
faut savoir que effectivement dumont qui
a été le plus touché par la crise j'ai
commise c'est aussi avant la pandémie
est aussi le sixième pays de l'ordre de
28 avec le taux de pauvreté le plus
élevé nous sommes un pays qui est juste
le gouvernement est arrivé au pouvoir
qu'elle
jours avant le début de la pandémie et
un mois ou deux mois avant le début de
la pandémie par exemple le réateur
spéciale le rapporteur spécial des
nations unies contre l'extrême pauvreté
et des droits de l'homme est venu dans
notre pays après un rapport jeu de la
pauvreté en espagne et dans ce rapport
qui était assez indigne ans est décédé
chose comme que si les espagnols se
promener dans certains quartiers de son
pays il serait sûrement incapable de
reconnaître ces quartiers comme les
quartiers appartenant à leur pays une
personne sur quatre en espagne et le
seuil de pauvreté
donc il faut il faut savoir que
l'espagne ne partait pas sur une bonne
base
le gouvernement est arrivé dans un
système où la santé publique a été
complètement démantelée il ya eu entre
2009 et 2014
douze mille deux cents professionnels
qui ont été virés delà du service de
santé public et pas que les
gouvernements précédents gouvernements
de droite du parti populaire mais aussi
parti socialiste ont mis en place d'une
sorte de privatisation du secteur public
de la santé espagnol avec des ventes
d'hôpitaux à des fonds vautours
avec 17 gestion publique privée dans
laquelle il ya toujours un intérêt
économique et je vous la santé ne prime
pas et c'est sur cette situation que
l'espagne est rentré un délit
aujourd'hui en espagne le masque est
obligatoire à partir de 6 ans mais
seulement dans les lieux publics je
crois il n'y a pas de masques dans la
rue
s'il ya des masques dans la rue et même
ce serait assez injuste j'ai déjà
entendu on certaines émissions pas en
france aussi en deux pays européens et
ailleurs que les espagnols ne porterait
pas le masque et qu' il y aura un manque
de civisme de la part des citoyens
espagnols n'ont ici le masque et le port
du masque est obligatoire avec les
espagnols le porte en les espaces
publics dans les bars dont le resto sauf
quand on mange on boit un verre mais
mais pour le porte
oui bon donc c'est pareil que chez nous
en revanche c'est dans les transports
vous avez une particularité quand on
prend les transports en commun on vous
demande votre nom et on le conserve
pendant quatre semaines au cas où il y
aurait
à foyer d'infection ça non dans cette
mesure ne me dit rien peut-être que dans
certaines communautés autonomes c'est
comme ça mais en principe non le
problème qu'il existe avec les avec les
transports publics c'est surtout quand
même même problème même question
services publics qui ont été démantelées
qui ont été qui ont souffert beaucoup de
réductions budgétaires et du coup le le
niveau de train qui passe et a été
réduit le niveau de transports publics
accessibles a été réduite et donc il ya
plus de l'agglomération et c'est aussi
une question devra résoudre et qui est
en train d'être en procès des treize
jours en ce moment là la population sort
normalement à la différence de la nôtre
on n'est pas confiné il ya des
communautés hôtes enfin je parle de
madrid actuellement on n'est pas content
in her on peut on peut sortir pour aller
travailler on sortir pour aller dans les
restaurants et dans les barques
il faut savoir que vu qu'il ya sept
cette gestion décentralisée de la
pandémie ici à madrid du gouvernement
est un gouvernement de droite parti
populaire soutenue par le box et le
parti d'extrême droite espagnole et
parle partie aux annonces qui serait le
parti libéral espagnol et il ya eu il ya
eu des tensions avec le gouvernement
central comme quoi madrid ce qui est ce
que la ville devraient être confinés est
ce qu'elle ne devrait pas être confiné
du moment où les compétences
appartiennent sont donc délégué sur ces
communautés autonomes
le gouvernement tente près ce qu'il peut
faire c'est maintenant sorte de parade
puis qui serait l'état d'alarmé et à
montrer son appui à ces communautés
n'ont finalement c'est la décision alors
est ce qu'aujourd'hui je crois que
l'espagne au départ de la pandémie a
souffert beaucoup comme la france du
mans que deux tests de l'absence
d'implication de traçage de masques
aussi est ce qu'aujourd'hui tous ces
problèmes sont résolus en espagne je
crois qu'il ya un certain nombre de deux
chiffres qui remontent un en catalogne
par exemple le air auquel tout le monde
est
le taux de reproduction auquel tout le
monde est attaché est passé de 1,43 la
semaine dernière à aca 0,9 donc ça
semble dire que la l'épidémie et nouveau
sous contrôle en catalogne et dans
d'autres communautés autonomes mais
aujourd'hui alors qu'en est il des tests
de et de tout ce qui manquait au départ
alors on se retrouve un peu dans la même
situation dans laquelle c'est un pays
qui n'a pas je pense que beaucoup de
pays européens ont eu cette même
situation et a pas eu une sorte de
protection de ses secteurs stratégiques
de de la production de co2 le sanitaire
l'espagne était très dépendante de la
production extérieure et au moment de
faire passer en ennemi il ya bien sûr
beaucoup de demandes de matériel
au début de la pandémie pendant la
première vague le gouvernement a cédé 1
a donné certaines sommes d'argent aux
communautés autonomes destinés à visée
s'cusez moi qui fais des hispaniques
parfois visé à ce que les communautés
autonomes achètent ces matériaux et
approvisionne les les hôpitaux et voilà
et certaines communautés autonomes ont
bien utilisé cet argent sont bien après
on vient acheter ces matériels et on a
d'autres comme par exemple la communauté
de madrid où la question que tout le
monde se pose et où est l'argent que le
gouvernement central a donné à cette
communauté où est-ce qu'ils avaient
investie parce que effectivement il n'y
a pas de matériel et on se retrouve dans
une situation très similaire à celle de
la première vague était inquiète en
effet ça n'est ce pas rien rien présager
rien présager de bon les espagnols sont
inquiets aujourd'hui pour l'avenir
particulièrement inquiets ou au
contraire ils ont l'impression que que
comme je le disais il ya ces deux
communautés autonomes qui sont en train
de s'en sortir
donc c'est juste un mauvais moment à
passer je pense qu'il faut il faudra
plus de jeunes et aux réactions de
certaines effectivement après c'est vrai
que on pourrait dire que la gestion
sanitaire a été mise en place en espagne
ont différé il n'est pas très différente
du reste des pays européens
on a eu notre état d'alarmé on a notre
petit le mans maintenant on a les
compétences des communautés autonomes
mais il ya quand même le gouvernement
central est là et qui soutient il ya des
fonds peut-être que le poma le point
positif de cette gestion de la commune
serais tu aurais que justement dans ce
gouvernement de coalition
il ya toute la responsabilité sanitaire
disons qui est déléguée dans les
ministères de santé et de sécurité
sociale
il ya ils sont entre guillemets géré par
le par le parti socialiste espagnol et
après il ya un deuxième bloc fait partie
des compétences en affaires sociales et
donc toutes les aides de l'état a mis en
place pour éviter que le le oud
reçoivent les citoyens espagnols soient
très grand en procès c'est le réseau
comme est en place sur l'état des dettes
sociales pour éviter que des espagnols
se trouve dans une mauvaise situation
qu'est ce qu'il ya de positif ici c'est
différent de ce que de comment être géré
la crise en 2008 pour la première fois
et a vraiment des aides sociales pour
les auto entrepreneurs
on a mis en place une sorte de rsa à
l'espagnol s'appelle inglès au minimum
vital et ben voila permet aux espagnols
d'avoir une quantité d'argent pour
éviter cette crise économique va
sûrement arriver partout donc fortement
la planète
on a aussi augmenté le salaire minimal
qui avant était à 600 euros maintenant
il se trouve pas notre 150 euros je ne
trouve pas voilà il ya une sorte de
mesures sociales qui a été mise en place
et qui est quand même très importante
parce que elle elle diffère 2 il y avait
été fait précédemment dans le pays et
qui surtout est aussi visé à protéger
les citoyens et pas uniquement voilà
s'enrichir ou par des faire ce qu'on
veut avec la santé publique avec les
transports publics avec des services
publics je reviendrai vers vous à la fin
de cette émission l'élite
arrivons maintenant ce maquis avec
jérôme texier la slovaquie ces cinq
millions et demi d'habitants comme la
comme la finlande et c'est le premier
pays du monde à opérer une campagne de
dépistage massif de toute la population
alors ça a été un sacré de barnum a
organisé un il a fallu trente quatre
mille médecins infirmières aides
soignants 5000 policiers 6000 militaires
tout ça pour organiser parce que c'est
beaucoup de monde s'est il a fallu
organiser 4900 points de dépistage et il
ya eu 2 millions mon ennemi de deux
slovaques qui se sont fait dépister en
une journée c'est considérable et d'un
seul coup on a vu apparaître par la même
occasion 26000 slovaquie était positif
donc un pour cent de ceux qui qui
s'était fait dépister normalement en
temps normal c'était entre 1000 et 3000
je crois qu'ils étaient repérés
contaminés par jour là c'est 26000 d'un
coup vous avez participé j'imagine que
c'était assez impressionnant
oui c'était impressionnant aussi si on
le prend où vous l'avez bien l'expliquer
sur une jolie sur la totalité du
week-end donc du 31 et du 1er novembre
on avait trois millions six cent mille
personnes qu'avec 1,06 pour cent de
personnes qui ont été identifiées en cas
positifs
donc on est à peu près à 38 mis un peu
plus de 38 villes 500 alors sur la
première journée puisqu'il y avait à peu
près les deux tiers qui se sont déplacés
on a vu des files d'attentes sur
bratislava et je pense sur les 4000
autres 900 points de test une
spécificité aussi il y avait ce qu'on
appelait les drive-in c'est-à-dire que
les personnes pouvaient se déplacer en
voiture et donc attendre dans la voiture
de se faire tester lui là on a vu un
matinales ont des files d'attentes des
gros problèmes de circulation
on a vu aussi des personnes qui ont lu
attendre 5 7 voire 10 heures dans leur
voiture pour pouvoir être testées alors
que le lendemain donc le dimanche on
avait
deux personnes il était assez facile de
se faire tester donc le lendemain avec
moins bon vous avez déjà des deux tiers
qui était inquiété tester la france
c'est 66 millions d'habitants c'est
beaucoup plus nous il aurait fallu six
cent mille personnes pour pour rien pour
l'organisation pour faire la même chose
que ce qu'on fait les slovaques
alors avec des mesures évidemment
ensuite prise si vous êtes des gatif
vous pouvez circuler librement si j'ai
bien compris si en revanche vous êtes
positif vous devez du xixe le lait chez
vous pendant au moins 14 jours c'est ça
mais c'est ça alors il y avait pour tout
ce qui est la logistique même le premier
ministre avait fait une référence au
débarquement de normandie donc il faut
raison garder il ya eu quand même un
gros dispositif de mise en place à la
base le test était c sur le reste du
volontariat est donc le premier ministre
lui le souhaitait l'obligé c'est à dire
que tout toutes les personnes à partir
de l'âge de 10 ans aillent se faire
tester en revanche cela à l'encontre de
la constitution et ce qui s'est passé
c'est que il y a eu c'est là où on a eu
un scepticisme justement où il ya eu
comme un chantage c'est à dire que si
vous faites le test et que vous êtes
négatif
vous avez un certificat ou comme on peut
la voir un certificat de sortie en
france
là vous avez un certificat qui atteste
que vous avez fait le test et que vous
êtes négatif et donc vous avez le droit
à moins de restrictions de sortie pour
aller faire vos achats mais que ce soit
non plus les achats de première
nécessité ou alimentaires mais aller
dans les centres commerciaux ont pouvoir
travailler il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
des entreprises des magasins peuvent
demander à ce que vous ayez nommé ayez
votre certificat négatif pour pouvoir
entrer soit pour consommer soit pour
travailler
donc en effet il ya eu ce scepticisme
autour de ça les gens qui n'ont pas
participé aux tests sont traités comme
s'ils étaient positifs doivent subir un
confinement de dix jours et donc
au delà de tout ça il y avait aussi la
le test antigel qui est on va dire
beaucoup plus rapide mais peut-être de
moins bonne qualité que les tests pcr et
donc on se posait la question de savoir
mais combien de test il va falloir faire
on conteste tout les négatifs puisque
vous faire tester le samedi les
agrégatifs cinq jours plus tard vous
pouvez devenir positif donc c'est pour
ça que le week-end dernier ils ont
relancé une autre une seconde vague de
tests mais qu'est-ce qui espère le
gouvernement à terme c'était
véritablement on sache qu'il a et et qu'
on puisse éradiquer réellement le la
maladie alors éradiquer la maladie
ça reste à voir puisque dans en france
on parle de faux positifs ici on va
parler de faux négatifs puisque j'ai
justement les tests antigènes vos
prélevés vont vous dire si vous êtes
négatif ou positif mais dans le test
anti génois vous disposez négatif à ce
moment là donc ça veut dire qu'on a à
peu près 25 mille personnes en slovaquie
qu'on considère comme vous faut négative
c'est à dire qu'ils doivent faire un
test ce week end normalement d'ici la
fin de cette semaine nous jusqu'au 14
novembre
on devrait avoir des décisions qui sont
prises mais les informations changent du
jour au lendemain c'est qu'il est très
difficile de savoir où va aller le
gouvernement aux paroles déjà ne
peut-être après ce deuxième test qui
s'est fait le week-end dernier alors
c'était pour les personnes fin pour les
districts qui avait entre au minimum 0
7% que positif donc pas toute la
slovaquie a été testé une deuxième fois
on a demandé aux personnes qui étaient
négatifs dans ces districts de retourner
se faire un resto le même vu des
personnes positives qui sont fait tester
pour savoir si ce n'est pas négatif
ok c'était assez assez chaotique aussi
elle se dévoile à mai à partir de 14 ans
on devrait avoir plus d'informations
puisque
l'idée c'est de savoir qu'est ce qui va
se passer après donc il ya une confusion
aussi augmentant le premier ministre
parlait d'un autre test à grande échelle
d'ici la fin du mois alors que les
personnes ne vaut les slovaques sont des
personnes très pragmatique il respecte
le profil mans le smic au film ans il
porte le masque pendant la première
vague au tout début il y avait très peu
de masse qui se sont fabriqué leurs
propres masques
donc on vraiment les personnes se sont
débrouillés avoir les masques et là où
c'est plus trop où se situe donc on sait
qu'il ya des personnes négatives qui ont
un peu plus un peu moins de restrictions
mais cela ne veut pas dire que ils sont
pas en semi confinement sénat qui
peuvent emmener leurs enfants à l'école
allait travailler mais on demande quand
même parce que les personnes restent
chez elles
voilà ce qui est très peu déplacement
une distanciation sociale et autant que
faire se noue pouvoir travailler à la
maison
est ce qu'il ya eu des réticences ou
même un début de révolte ne serait ce
que sur les réseaux sociaux de la part
de la population
quand on a ces annonces et ce grand plan
de dépistage massif en france il ya
beaucoup de gens enfin beaucoup
peut-être pas bon ça il ya des gens qui
s'expriment qui pensent que le virus
n'existe pas qui pense que tout ça est
un est un est un complot international
pour nous soumettre politiquement
mentalement physiquement
si on leur annonçait demain grand plan
de dépistage massif
j'imagine qu'ils créeraient au génocide
oui alors c'est très disparates ans il
ya quand même avant l'annoncé du
confinement une manifestation qui a
regroupé quelques personnes avec des
échauffourées avec avec la police avant
ça il y avait quand même aussi des
manifestations au niveau du port du
masque pour les enfants à l'école ou
pendant la deuxième vague
par exemple aujourd'hui les lycées les
universités font sont fermées donc les
étudiants doivent étudier à la maison
alors que les maternelles les écoles
primaires les crèches sont ouvertes
donc il ya cette confusion qui est
toujours là pas de manifestation tant
que tel ce qui est intéressant ce qui
est rigolo c'est que on n'a pas de
couvre-feu en revanche ils ont mis en
place la possibilité pour les personnes
de sortir entre 1h et 5h du matin donc
on a vu en effet dans les réseaux
sociaux des personnes qui m ont décidé
de se regrouper pendant ces heures la
boue pendant la nuit mais je dirais que
le problème c'est de savoir c'est que si
on fait les tests
aujourd'hui donc les personnes vont être
traqués je veux dire est entre
guillemets administrativement pendant
qu'on sait qui est ce qui a été testé et
qui est ce qu'il ya un résultat positif
est négative
donc on en revient à un petit peu si
vous voulez à la question de savoir
comment ça se passera si les jours il y
aura un axe donc on peut se poser la
question
quelqu'un qui a accès qui s'est fait
vacciner pourra-t-il travailler ou pas
s'il a le vaccin ou pas donc l'idée de
tester toute la population dans le dans
le cadre de tester reconfirmer protéger
et réduire l'épidémie est bonne
cocktail maintenant ce qu'il ya derrière
tout ça au gouvernement de nous le dire
en espérant qu'il n'y ait pas encore une
fois ce chantage de ce qu'ils sont on
pourrait diviser la population de ceux
qui sont positifs négatifs et des cieux
et de ce qu'ils sont on dire anti test
ou anti masque alors dernière question
vous me répondez rapidement parce que je
veux la pause et à mes trois autres
invités de bratislava comment voit-on la
france la france aux prises avec la
pandémie quelle image avez vous alors
nous en tant que français je suis assez
inquiet je pense que
je peux discuter avec certains amis et
collègues slovaques qu'ils comprennent
que en fait en france l'image commencé
pour vraiment s'immisce dans la vie des
personnes jusqu'au domicile
moi qui suit les informations de ce qui
se passe en france
j'entends qu'on peut parler de porter
les masques à la maison donc on a
l'impression qu'on me demande vraiment
aux personnes et on leur dit ce qu'ils
doivent faire ce qu'ils doivent pas le
faire en se maquille on arrive quand
même à un jeu dire et à faire confiance
à la responsabilité de chacun des
individus et donc de respecter les
consignes mais en france m'a vraiment le
pressing mais par exemple on en parlait
tout à l'heure du du du de la répression
c'est une impression très forte en
france qui est visible qui fait l'écho
et qui n'est pas du tout cas bratislava
où on peut pas non plus demeurer
l'attestation donc justement à 99% des
populations qui est négative donc ce qui
se passe en france c'est assez
inquiétant alors même question à aller
lice à madrid qu'elle est quelle est la
vision que les madrilènes ont de la
situation française
je pense que la situation est différente
dans une situation un peu plus compliqué
mais par exemple les multimarques et a
étudié à parier et à paris actuellement
et on a tous les deux le couvre-feu on a
tous les ans un peu les mêmes sans
sécurité et les mêmes tout donc je pense
que c'est une situation si différentes
il ya aussi eu des possibilités des
protestations en espagne disons que la
situation de l'incertitude et de quel
point on va devoir être pendant des mois
jean-françois denard en allemagne
comment voit-on les français toujours
avec un peu de de condescendance
situation allemand enfin les allemands
ont un peu changé d'avis
dans la première période du confinement
dans le premier première crise
c'était très important de fermer les
frontières de et c'est ce qui fait d'eux
j'habite à quai dans bright donc de
l'autre côté du rhin par rapport à
strasbourg il ya beaucoup de français
qui vient de faire des courses
d'allemagne sur les produits qui sont
moins chers
le premier est le tabac ensuite y'a des
couches pour enfants il ya plein de
choses comme ça donc à premier au
premier confinement ils avaient tous
fermés il avait interdit d'être enfin le
la traversée du rhin et c'est cette fois
ci on a eu l'impression que c'était
mieux compris je pense
il ya des mesures qui n'ont pas été
prises dans un sens où finalement on
appelait on a fait un peu face aux mêmes
choses donc je suis pas tout à fait pas
tout à fait vrai au point de vue des
chiffres mais voilà donc d'ailleurs de
plus de solidarité et la même question
elle à helsinki
je pense que les finlandais sont assez
étonnés de la dureté des mesures en
france
quand j'ai expliqué à des amis des
collègues vraiment l'été dans les
aboutissants du confinement
je pense que ça remet les choses en
perspective pour eux est je pense qu'ils
sont assez au courant de l'ampleur de la
de la catastrophe sanitaire en france
est évidemment ça attriste beaucoup de
chants de voir que comme la situation
est difficile en france et dans d'autres
pays frontaliers et ils savent bien que
la france est un des pays les plus
touchés et il se rend compte vraiment
que la situation reste très précaire et
que et que finalement on n'a peut-être
pas mal de chance d'être dans un pays où
ou la gestion de la crise a été hâtée
simone et les conditions qui sont restés
plutôt plutôt bornes
et oui c'est une chance je vous remercie
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci
et de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
au prochain numéro
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
désir